well at this very moment Russia is
marking the 74th anniversary of the
Soviet victory over Nazi Germany in
World War two Russians across the
country commemorate Victory Day with the
biggest celebration by far taking place
in Moscow's Red Square we're looking at
pictures live pictures of that parade
right now from Moscow in the lavish
parade thousands of troops are marching
past President Vladimir Putin and other
high-ranking Russian officials
besides the servicemen over 130 military
vehicles and 74 aircraft are involved in
the display Victory Day commemorates the
surrender of Nazi Germany in 1945 in
Russia had celebrated a day later than
in other countries because the official
documents were signed after midnight
Moscow time let's bring in our
correspondent in Moscow me a drug Sarge
he's standing by there right in the
thick of it at Red Square me a drug if
you can hear me this is a nationwide
holiday in Russia millions are watching
the military parade as they have for
decades what does this parade mean for
Russians today
well this is a very important day for
the Russians when I visit Russian
families there towards no family that is
not going to mention that their
grandfather or any other relative fought
during World War two and some of them of
course died so this is a very very
important date for the Russians but
today they are in a festive mood
military parade right behind me is being
broadcast live from the Red Square much
of the city center will be closed for
the festivities there are hundreds of
events going on in the city for Victory
Day you'll hear groups from all over the
world singing and dancing in downtown
Moscow you will see retro cross in the
streets people wearing costumes
traditional Russian dresses Soviet
military uniforms so you will see all
this here in Moscow of course there is
also a political message of this parade
the message is we are strong and no one
can pause America critics say this
parade has been turned into an
extravagant propaganda exercise for
Russian leader Vladimir Putin what's
your assessment
yeah I think this is shoe you know
there's a recent poll showing that
Russian support for large-scale military
parades decrease in 2019 separate poll
indicated that the share of Russian
supporting Putin's military intervention
in Syria for example has fallen below
50% since August 2017
so people here in Russia make less money
that food Anna for example before 2014
people are really tired of years of
growing state-controlled militarism to
put it in a nutshell in Iraq thank you
so much DWS mere drug storage there in
Moscow
[Music]